en este vídeo quiero hablar del concepto
de los números primos que es un número
primo
en realidad este no es para nada un
concepto complicado los números primos
son de sus conceptos muy importantes en
la ciencia con los que se construyen
otros conceptos más avanzados observarás
con el tiempo en tus estudios de
matemáticas que te encuentras a los
números primos en diferentes situaciones
y también los números pudimos utilizar
en técnicas como la criptografía en si
es el nombre ahorita no te dice mucho es
una técnica que utilizas en algunos de
los programas de tu computadora para
transmitir y almacenar información de
manera segura eso es la criptografía
pero bueno no importa mucho ahorita en
entrar en esos detalles y mejor
regresemos a nuestro tema de los números
primos y voy a empezar por dar una
definición del número primo la
definición es bastante sencilla y se
refiere a dos condiciones la primera me
dice que para que un número sea primo
tiene que ser un número natural número
na
bueno los números naturales son los
números que utilizamos para contar los
enteros positivos por ejemplo es muy
simple es el 1 en 23 y así en adelante
esos son los números naturales la
segunda condición me dice que para que
un número sea número primo tiene que ser
divisible
exactamente por dos números naturales
exactamente exactamente entre dos
números naturales exactamente
- naturales
y estos son
el mismo o sea él
el número en cuestión y el número 1
bien esta es la definición del número
primo si en este momento no es muy clara
no te preocupes vamos a hacer una serie
de ejercicios que permitirán aclarar
este concepto tan importante así que
vamos a empezar por el primero de los
números naturales el primero de los
números naturales pues es el
y el 1 es divisible entre 1 pero este es
un caso especial el del 1 porque el 1
sólo es divisible entre 1 o sea solo es
divisible entre un número y nuestra
definición dice que tiene que ser entre
dos números entonces por raro que pueda
sonar el número uno no es primo
no es primo
ahora vamos con el número 2
el número 2 es divisible entre 1 y es
divisible entre 2 entonces el número 2
si es primo a los que son primos este
los voy a subrayar a perdón a encerrar
en una en un circulito ahora sigamos con
el 3
el número 3
es divisible entre 1 y entre 3
entonces el 3 también es un número primo
vayamos ahora con el 4
el 4 vamos a buscar un color este el 4
el 4 es divisible entre 1
divisible entre 4 pero también es
divisible entre 2 ya que dos por dos es
cuatro
entonces el 4 es divisible entre 3
números naturales no cumplen nuestra
definición entonces el 4 no es primo
continuamos ahora con el 5
el 5
es divisible entre el 1 y es divisible
entre el 5
entonces el 5 definitivamente este es
otro número primo
sigamos con el 6
el 6 y el 6 es divisible entre 1 pero
también es divisible entre 6 y también
es divisible entre 2 y también es
divisible entre 3 entonces este tiene
cuatro divisiones pues el 6 tampoco es
un número primo y de hecho si observas
el único número par que es primo es el 2
todos los demás no son primos ahora
vamos con el 7 el 7 es divisible entre 1
y entre 7 y por supuesto el siete es un
número primo podemos pensar en los
números primos
como unos bloques de construcción de los
demás números es decir todos los números
están hechos por números primos nos
podría recordar como en la época que se
pensaba que todo estaba hecho de átomos
y los átomos eran indivisibles en ese
sentido podríamos pensar acerca de los
números primos
claro o sea si observamos estos que
tenemos aquí es por ejemplo el 6 pues el
6 yo lo puede expresar como dos por tres
es decir el producto de dos números
primos el 7 no puedo descomponerlo claro
vas a decir el 7 es igual a 1 por 7 pero
bueno este es el mismo el 4 pues también
claro el 4 2 por 2 veamos qué pasa con
números más grandes por ejemplo vamos a
escoger el número digamos el número 16
entonces yo escribo aquí el 16 y lo que
tendríamos que observar es que si lo
puedo descomponer en productos de otros
números entonces bueno el primero que me
viene a la cabeza y el más sencillo es
que es 1 por 16 claro esto es válido
pero también el 16 pues no es un número
primo porque mira lo puedo poner como 2
por 8 o puedo ponerlo como cuatro por
cuatro y puede encontrar infinidad de
combinaciones para expresar el 16 como
producto de otros números
entonces el 16 no es un número primo
ahora veamos el 17 bueno el 17
pudiéramos expresar el 17 como producto
de otros números que estén digamos entre
1 y 17
por ejemplo el 2 pues no funciona el 3
tampoco funciona el 4 definitivamente
tampoco bueno se ve que el 5 y el 6 y el
7 entonces no existe números naturales
entre 1 y 17 que me permitan expresar a
17 como producto de ellos entonces 17 es
un número primo
a ver ahora te voy a poner uno que
realmente va a estar difícil y puede
confundir a muchas personas a ver veamos
el 51 y el 51 ok la pregunta es es primo
tal vez sería buena idea de tener el
vídeo en este momento y que pensaras una
solución
y lo que hay que pensar es si el 51 lo
puedo expresar como producto de otros
números que no sean 1 ó 51
y te voy a dar la respuesta de una vez
el 51 no es primo porque el 51 lo puedo
expresar como tres veces 17 3 por 17 es
51 por lo que 51 no es primo bien espero
que con estos ejemplos y ya tengas una
idea más precisa de lo que se tratan los
números primos y seguiremos trabajando
estos conceptos en próximos vídeos